well someone saw Terry Potter movies I'm
falling down that's alcohol this child
is having nightmares about the future
has anyone checked her for
midi-chlorians also Alice can't remember
the animated movie well enough to
realize it was her do you think I've
come off the bat yes yes I do
at least until 10 years from now when
this you're babbling about actually
happens to you for the second time but
even then you'll probably have no proof
so yes my answer is yes I'm sticking
with yes/no mad bonkers off your head
but I'll tell you a secret all the best
people are
this is patently untrue and the reason
why we have Donald Trump is a
presidential candidate it's a dream
Alice nothing can harm you then and then
I immediately started fantasizing about
Freddy Krueger showing up in this movie
and I could think of nothing else I'd be
fine if the movie just started here wait
so close each other
who knew Alice in Wonderland is an
extension of Jane Austen's world also
yes corsets work terrible I don't argue
that but I do argue the lazy
storytelling cliche of sticking a corset
hating heroine into the plot set during
corsets are commonplace time only one
Solis is saying since I can remember
Wonderland has been haunting her dream
for 13 years and I'm sure it means
something super important but right now
it just feels like a lot of wasted time
on the part of Wonderland
ed Sheeran seems disappointed with the
hot girl he's prearranged to dance with
also the dude you're being arranged to
be married to is totally and completely
unacceptable cliche flock of sprites I
was wondering what it would be like to
fly why would you spend your time
thinking about such an impossible thing
movie spends way too much time telling
us how humorless and unimaginative this
world Alice lives in is wonder if your
mother knows that you two swim naked in
lavish rooms pond the whole snap where's
the footage of that I mean she totally
owned them right there right I mean
assuming there's verifiable footage of
said naked swimming you know for science
he won't you're better than Lord Q Lord
being disgusting he could always paint
the roses red what an odd thing to say
but alas he cannot marry me unless he
renounces his revered it's tragic isn't
it
hairy girl slowly backs away from
presumably crazy person in order to
continue her chase after a CGI possibly
imaginary rabbit in a waistcoat hello
Alice's sister's husband makes out with
the mistress in basically full view of
everyone
the Sarah's version of a courts
artists must work really fast I have
already painted this much of the scene
in front of him in like 10 seconds also
Alice is nowhere near that blonde dude
Alice flees a public engagement event
with hundreds of spectators and not one
person follows her also this is some
otherworldly color coordination for this
engagement party
where are you saying the entire kingdom
only has the range of white to sky-blue
to choose from and so why Alice doesn't
die from just the extended free fall
alone falling piano catches up to her
then slows so she's falling faster and
this entire scene is giving Galileo the
finger underground ex machina bed cool
transition but how did she suspend
herself for even a few seconds up there
thinking it was the floor is she really
trying this right now how stupid is she
also could we at least see what she sees
outside the door give the character some
motivation give us some motivation for
hoping she gets outside I mean come on
only after trying every door then trying
the key in every door did she finally
see the super obvious treatme potion on
the table of course if there is one
thing I will always do without delay
it's that I will drink any liquid in
front of me that says dreaming so you
dream it is you mean you ran away from
that Hamish dude found a tree and
immediately went to sleep or does she
think it's a dream someone tell me how
to enjoy things I'm not a perv I promise
but why did the outer dress not shrink
after the potion but the inner
undergarment thing did shrink Oh looking
for here is consistency yo you'd see she
would remember all this from the first
time Wonderland creature would be
amazing at cinema sins now see that's
just an insult right there this girl
will do whatever food stuffs tell her to
do
and now the slip dress undergarment that
shrunk when she drank the liquid appears
not to be growing with Alice after the
bite of eat me cake one of the rules
with the clothing
Tim Burton heaven also looks like Alice
found herself in Sam Raimi's Oz also
this isn't even a nightie this is a
whole separate dress she was apparently
wearing under the initial dress
rocking-horse flying thing yep that's a
bird walking with a cane right there hmm
are you voice of Alan Rickman further
proof I'm watching a Harry Potter movie
fab just being the day you slay the
Jabberwocky are you can serious they
took Jabberwocky a nonsense poem and
turned it into an Alice slays the
Jabberwocky story someone pounded their
hand on the table and said this Alice
story isn't lower the Rings enough let's
have her kill a monster also here's yet
another goddamn prophecy stealing any
suspense you could have possibly
conjured during watching this will be
pretty much fast-forwards itself for us
not Heartland taping now that the movie
really has no place to go here's a
monster that's not the way needles and
eyes work either of these assholes
suffer any injuries whatsoever from the
very dangerous looking thorn walloping
bull Wonderland branded Disney Castle
presence of Helena Bonham Carter further
proof I'm watching a Harry Potter movie
no one will be seated during the who
stole my tarts interrogation to the Frog
scene also of all the things a frog
would steal tarts seriously not flies or
some other sensible frog thing but tarts
Jesus also who eats tarts in such a way
as to leave this kind of sloppy ass
evidence no joke straight-up how the is
this fish moving like this it's like his
tail is feet somehow which is stupid but
if this universe has some kind of
advanced evolution that maybe make sense
movie care to explain that's why I
thought I'd know that tangled mess of
hair anyway is it Alice you just said
you knew what's she doing with my
darling Jabberwocky I mean you can't
decipher what a sword-wielding hot chick
is doing to a monster in this picture
for my wife I'm puffs as well
voice of Timothy's fall further evidence
I'm watching a Harry Potter really go
just will believe anything that's true
but if horses can talk and are so smart
how did they ever allow assholes to ride
them it looks like you ran afoul of
something with wicked clues voice of
Stephen Fry further proof I'm playing a
Harry Potter game the moon turns into a
smiling cat face that actually ends up
looking more like toothless from How to
Train Your Dragon than a moon cat but
whatever
but the Mad Hatter completely
disrespects a solid tea party set up my
twist brooches the wrong choice if I
hear this wrong Alice one more time I'm
gonna personally put rat poison in this
mouse's teacup the next time I dream off
to wonder later what happened that day
was not my phone yet I now turn em to
save your own skin
either this is what I'm supposed to
remember from the animated Alice in
Wonderland or it's some really forced
exposition regardless it gets a sick on
that day I shall Futterwacken vigorously
it's supposed to be a dance but it
sounds extremely like masturbation drink
this cupcake this chick ever refused to
eat or drink strange things throw step
on her suddenly she's like the food
drink version of Jim Carrey in the yes
man let me out
did you not see bad guys a minute ago do
you really think you've been stuffed in
a teapot for no reason don't bloody
begin dog that thinks he's going to get
his family back if he finds Alice
retreats because of some sort of loyalty
gibberish scoffs please oh yeah by the
way who makes the tea in the scones and
everything on this table and where and
where do they keep the proper cookware
and utensils it isn't
up until now Alice hasn't needed any
tailoring on her clothes whether she
becomes big or small I love traveling
pot belly just Alice please but that hat
is big enough for several tiny creatures
you were much more much here you've lost
your muchness and this is what passes
for dialogue at a Tim Burton film these
days in down some seams machine super
nebulous something's missing in your
soul dilemma well now power this film's
plot tell me will prick queens Tom it
was him you mean she asked for details
about the Red Queen's evilness on the
site of said evilness just by chance the
I top carnival with Finn employed at
court now we have a flashback within a
dream that isn't really a dream what the
Red Queen did this is unforgivable it's
made everything a CGI wasteland the sad
Hatter Oh Alice doesn't fall off this
hat you were supposed to lead them away
the Hatter trusted you were from ups
which is why I totally pretended you
weren't in the Hatter's teapot earlier
my motivations tend to change whenever
the plot requires literally 37 seconds
of her riding a doll
there's a new one went across and it's
straight out of the movie labyrinth
smell good tastes bad she's riding giant
floating faces and instead of being
impressed or freaked out I'm mostly
thinking about human tissue
decomposition and how its accelerated by
water bear
dogs ability to throw a hat Eclipse his
most people's ability to throw a
baseball
using the Flamingo as a croquet racket
to hit a ball made out of a hedgehog
it's not only cruel it's a finger to
physics which would suggest that a limp
flamingo head and neck would exert
practically zero force on a lying still
Hedgehog why would she want to eat the
growing cake right now
what happened your close eye out
gruesome I've been growing an awful lot
lately this flimsy excuse bulk it
actually works I need to pig hair Pig
footstools
not one disney castle but do disney
castles have you seen a hat around here
why does the porcupine squeak but every
other animal in this world talks do you
still have the Bandersnatch I'm right
here I was about to say aha
gotcha she clearly wasn't carrying this
eye around with her before but no she
had it in this previous scene but I knew
I had to send something so how about why
she decided to haul this thing around
with her in the first place
Alice wants George McFly away easily and
runs down a hallway and the movie wants
to take away to be that this other
asshole chick saw the whole exchange
really I feel I Alice believes that just
because she returned the Bandersnatch
acai that it will just let her search
the place for the vorpal sword which it
does stain well you slept all night in
here so I guess you passed the test
the key has been around my neck all your
Dino the whole school damn she has a
whole pot of horsefly urine which then
makes me wonder how that's collected and
in such large quantities three coins
from a dead man's pocket how is it that
the good white Queen uses such morbid as
ingredients for a shrinking potion I
mean dead fingers
coins from a dead man's pocket horsefly
urine can you at least put some sugar in
that someone here would like to speak
with you but they'll wait until it's
dark and you've changed clothes I'm
Alice not that one how do you know you
said so yourself
I said you are not hardly a palace but
you're much more hurt now this is some
obi-wan kenobe little both appear will
you stop doing that blue caterpillar
shows up simply to tell Alice that she
might be Alice after all and she needs
to kill the Jabberwocky something she
already knows and then disappears well
someone saw Pirates of the Caribbean
okay but since when does the Cheshire
Cat have the power to change you to
other people and how did they miss the
color of his eyes during the walk from
his prison cell to the execution why
don't you sleep Jeff walk yourself you
must have the power it's against my vows
to harm any living creature Oh
also I keep those vowels until it's time
to make a potion of some sort which
requires the ill-gotten blood a former
living creatures is your hot Cheshire
cat with a hat x mark it up have you any
idea why a raven is like a writing desk
approximately 60% of the dialogue in
this movie is have you any idea why a
raven is like a writing desk and she's
not the real Alice who will step forth
to be champion for the White Queen that
would be I know my bald fat Ron Weasley
and his twin volunteer for certain death
despite being comically stupid thus far
in the film I'm surprised they even
understood the question if you were just
gonna refer to the scroll thing to
decide whether anybody could help Alice
fight the Jabberwocky
why did you bother asking anyone if they
could help no the cyano how isn't this
common knowledge already didn't they
open this up earlier and the blue
caterpillar said she would slay the
Jabberwocky how did they miss this the
first time
Alice spends a lot of time pacing and
thinking about this decision but my main
question is why did you rip off
Rivendell you're just as dim-witted the
first time you were here you called it
Wonderland as I recall Wow
also the word Wonderland is all it takes
to help Alice remember the previous
adventure enough to get the hero's job
done in this adventure why didn't anyone
remind her about Wonderland prior to
this moment hey also Alice remembers
doing all this same sheet as a child but
isn't this a recurring dream didn't she
say earlier in the movie she was still
having this dream how could she forget
all this stuff why does it seem more
real now how is anything supposed to
stand up to an army this size even a
magic Gandalf Alice Aragorn would be
useless against these numbers right
while you weren't watching
Alice tamed this creature found some
form-fitting armor and also consulted
the script none of these chess head army
soldiers can see a goddamn thing through
their helmets which means their magic
just warriors that are mere pawns oh the
irony
blue scene armies happen to meet on a
literal giant checker just bored because
imagery Dan that jabberwockies
introduction is literally 5% of this
film's runtime one does a potion that
can make it shrink
Alice starts remembering six impossible
things but all of them are things she
knows to be true impossible voice of
Christopher Lee further proof I'm
watching The Lord of the Rings movie not
your insignificant banner
once
Jabberwocky sees an animate object as
his old foe as if Alice could just drop
the sword right here and let it do all
the work because the Hatter interfered
apparently both armies are now allowed
to discharge and do battle which makes
me wonder why Alice has to keep fighting
the Jabberwocky at that point
Alice in Wonderland will now end with a
color muted Lord of the Rings facsimile
Domino soldiers Mad Hatter sword fights
with the knave and I think I honestly
care less about this sword fight than I
do the one in Lincoln I feel kind of
like even though the Jabberwocky doesn't
know where she is his super lightening
breath should have still electrocuted
her entirely metal ass Jabberwocky head
is nice enough to follow the stairs back
down why did you do that
the White Queen said she couldn't kill
the Red Queen because it's against her
vows which means she really wanted to
kill her but now somebody offers to do
the job and you stop him
what kind of hippie shit is this flutter
wagon also movie Baro is happy dance
ending from Tropic Thunder but uses
music from something out of 1994 and I
don't give a shit what they were going
forward this is a sin this take me home
if that's what you choose the blood of
the Jabberwocky is what will bring Alice
home basically what you're saying is she
had no choice but to slay the
Jabberwocky which is against the spirit
of your making your own choices that
this story preaches Alice is being shot
back out of the rabbit hole but then she
has to still climb out of a hole the
blood of the Jabberwocky is like an uber
driver who can't get the last five feet
to your destination these assholes are
still standing here and don't give me
the time stand still because she went to
another world bullsh she's been gone way
long enough for everyone to give up and
go home
sorry komari y'all the right man for me
there's a trouble of your digestion no
need to be a dick about it
damn guys no prints on Imogen you need
to talk to someone about these delusions
I'm going to add 100 sins for this bull
spread here this whole movie has been
about how crazy people are the best
people and how impossible is a good
thing and now the main character the
movie is Forbes her that she's crazy and
needs help for her delusions I'd remove
two hundred sins if the prince showed up
right now to rub it in Alice's stupid
face I happen to love rabbits especially
white one that's racist you two remind
me of some funny boys I met in a dream
not really though not even close
but it sounds like a funny insult to
people who actually enjoyed this movie
which can't be many right
and Futterwacken is such a
disappointment why don't go all the way
to China I mean Alice is going to be
responsible for the opium wars that
started between the UK and China
that's unbefitting of a Disney era win'
I mean heroine also how is this
something she's been wanting to do all
these years
this is boring-ass trade route doesn't
she want to invent a clapper bomber or a
giant bragging when I think Alice in
Wonderland what I really think of is
Avril Lavigne you take the red pill you
stay in Wonderland and I show you how
deep the rabbit-hole goes
do you think I've gone round the back
ladies and gentlemen it is a great honor
that I present to you His grace The
Count of Monte Cristo even so I can say
far far away can you walk with me I know
the walls have ears but apparently the
shrubbery does to you yes Ned Stark had
many admirers and how many stepped
forward when the executioner came for
his head
give me eat me raw grain identity has
popped me to you
we have
you
but I am flying and from RAM here you
are no blanket and I think I'll miss you
most of all